primero por qué fue tan decepcionante
este resultado de la Cumbre
Bueno muy buenas noches Muchas gracias
por la invitación
déjame decirle que yo no creo yo pienso
que la decepción es
de pronto en el hecho de que nosotros
tenemos un desafío tan grande para poder
cerrar la la distancia sobre sobre
nuestros objetivos en temas de
mitigación pero yo pienso que lo que
nosotros vimos aquí en en Egipto es un
resultado basado en la justicia
climática con la adopción de de este
nuevo fondo para las pérdidas y daños
amplificados por el cambio climático
Entonces yo pienso que nosotros tenemos
que primeramente ver cuáles son las
implicaciones de lo que sucedió aquí en
Egipto con ese fondo y cuál es el
mensaje Cuál es la herencia que deja la
17 sobre todas las personas que están
buscando un mensaje de Esperanza para
saber cómo cómo el cambio climático está
siendo realmente
atacado por por los poderes y los
gobiernos de todo el mundo y yo pienso
que lo que sucedió en Egipto hoy es una
prueba de que el mundo puede realmente
aceptar como podemos responder a los
impactos climáticos que no estamos
viendo más y más en todas partes del
mundo
señor Eddy Pero qué fue lo que impidió
que los países adoptaran un tono más
fuerte para exigir medidas hacia la
reducción de emisiones contaminantes que
es lo que ha dicho la Unión Europea
bueno mire yo pienso que lo primero que
tenemos que decir allí es que la
convención la convención marco de lo del
cambio climático de las Naciones Unidas
fue ha sido
instrumentalizada para que cosas ligadas
a las energías fósiles no sean
no estén incluidas dentro de las
negociaciones climáticas pero hemos
visto actores eh países por ejemplo como
Colombia como Noruega Canadá Estados
Unidos que quieren hoy en día que
nosotros
avancemos sobre las posibilidades que
tenemos para reducir nuestra dependencia
en la energía fósiles lo que tenemos que
pensar también es Cómo podemos
movilizarnos no solamente en la con 27
pero en la organización de la con 28
para que enviemos un mensaje a la de la
con 28 para poder eventualmente
pensar en un resultado que permite
controlar la expansión de la energía
fósil dentro de la próxima cop en la
cual los gobiernos se van a encontrar
otra vez y para mí eso es lo que yo veo
como como un elemento positivo estamos
viendo muchos más países Colombia Canadá
por ejemplo Canadá es un país que que
exporta petróleo hoy en día pidiendo que
la convención
pueda pueda pueda pueda hablar de de del
fin de la de la expansión de la
ingeniería fósiles Yo pienso que tenemos
que hablar de esa coalición de países
que estamos viendo ahora mismo